we are super excited we're so excited
about our next guest none other than you
know him star trek actor and now real
space traveler william shatner this
hollywood legend was part of a
four-member crew that blasted to the
edge of space yesterday on a rocket from
jeff bezos blue origin at 90 he's the
oldest person to go to space and i was
so touched yesterday i know we all were
he got very emotional when he talked
about the experience after landing back
on earth take a listen
what you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can imagine
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just
it's extraordinary
william shatner joins us now good
morning to you and congratulations and
bravo to you william shatner i have to
tell you it was it was magical honestly
it was magical watching you we were all
sitting here at the table watching you
in real time and your description of
what what you experienced and how you
were feeling
choked a lot of people up and i'm
wondering i know you said yesterday
you're still processing all of it but
what made you so emotional specifically
it's almost uh encode
to describe to
to specifically
tell you exactly what it was it was so
generalized and
the reason i felt that
was because before going
i had thought you know what how will i
describe what i see and i've prepared
plans uh like a word that maybe somebody
else hadn't used i i've got uh
uh an album out there called bill right
now with a song in it uh so far from the
moon uh another occasion so i was
thinking how can i how could i describe
it and what happened was
i'm looking out the window
and there it it turns out that nobody
told me about it i mean the the
limitations there's about a 50 mile
skin
that the earth has of air
these and the air reflects the light and
turns blue so we see a blue sky we grow
up and live and die blue sky right
the spaceship and i like to call it that
punch through that at 2 500 miles an
hour 50 50 miles 2500 miles an hour so
within a count of two or three it goes
from blue
bang and suddenly it's black
and you see this black and that's
space and
eternity and
and the mystery of the cosmos and but
it's black and it's death and it's
and just down there
is the blue you're at the top of the
blue looking down on the earth and you
get these cliches it's so fragile it's
all of that
but this little blue covering
and and
what is there is lurking and what is
there is nourishing
it was dramatized again the very cliches
we hear again and again we're so fragile
we hang by a string we hang by
the pollution we're doing
we're in the
in the beginning of a terrible thing is
going to happen to the world unless we
do something immediately about it but
william you know what you know yesterday
you had told us or before you went you
said you were nervous and you were
afraid and i was wondering what you were
thinking when you were going up because
they had a couple of delays what were
you thinking at that moment were you
ever when once you were on board did you
were you still afraid
oh my god oh are you kidding you're
lying back there and you know that
there's uh all this explosive material
and
we know it's safe they've made this blue
origin has made it safe i want to
emphasize that so it's safe
but it's one thing to say it's safe and
it's another thinking oh i remember
o-rings and i remember explosion
you know so so you can be told it's safe
but if the dread is there and as an
actor i've had to deny emotions
be in front of a camera and something
terrible has happened in my personal
life i can't show that
so i developed a system of denial and i
had been denying how nervous and uh i
was
until i'm lying down on the seat and
things are culminating beneath me and
i'm thinking hey wait a minute i'm
frightened
and then when all those things that they
described would happen but they don't
tell you they don't know
because who's been in g forces of five
and six g forces who's been in
weightlessness how do you describe
weightlessness
being in it is totally different from
any description you can have you're
floating but you're floating your gut is
floating your head is floating
outside is
you're you're immersed in things that
are indescribable and every and because
people
the 600 people who've been there say oh
yeah it's dark and i'm telling you it's
dark i'm telling you it's dark
hey bill
it's like a truth that suddenly comes to
you
and you don't want to dissipate it you
don't want to lose it you want to hold
it for the rest of your life
tuck it somewhere but there is something
coming our way folks that we've got to
avoid and the only way to avoid it is to
look at it we need to clean our planet
up now
or our grandchildren are going to be in
terrible shape
well bill william uh if everybody or a
good portion of us were able to have the
experience that you are describing this
morning if it were more widespread how
do you think the world might be a
different place
well
because it's so easy what's coming our
way we all know this what's coming our
way is horrific
so it's easier to bury your
hand in the sand well i'm not going to
think about it you have to think about
it and it's terrible to think about it's
terrible that they're building 20-foot
walls in miami to in front of people's
homes who spend millions of dollars for
the view of the ocean and they're
erecting a 20-foot wall because the seas
are rising half of
florida is going to be underwater do you
realize half of florida's going to be
underwater in our children's lifetime
wow i mean i have to
i have to ask you this because i feel
like you have a more profound answer to
this question after what you have done
i would like to
what is the meaning of life and death
because i feel like you've seen both
yesterday
life is to be a participant
in this incredibly beautiful
uh planet of ours i was in texas with
the mountains and this and the clouds
and the and the animals that live there
and and it's beautiful beautiful that's
life
space with all its mystery and and and
and uh
things to find and and the giant forces
that work and the expanding universe
when they should be contracting and all
everything is so mysterious and
but it's unknown
it's known here this is beautiful that
you know that's far and full of fire and
fury and we don't know what it is we
know what it is right here
yeah you came back safely we're so glad
to see
concerns our worldly concerns are
pressing upon us now though we have to
say goodbye william thank you very much
i can think of a few politicians who may
enjoy the view you're describing might
change their outlook on things